[Music]
[Music]
you dare enter this [ __ ] house
it's Wednesday June 22nd
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive my head is [ __ ] up
but who gives a [ __ ] about the head
we'll start with the head do what's in
your heart
what's it in that sack come what's in
your [ __ ] so we understand me I'm
sitting here getting some vitamin D
smoking at booty salutes getting ready
for my day I got a big day I'm gonna
talk to this man about a dog
I gotta go to drills a little jiu-jitsu
I gotta get my haircut done I got a spot
at the improv little scenic over a
[ __ ] submission submission jujitsu
blend my main man China but I got a big
day and I know you do too so I won't
waste your time let me tell you
something you know uncle Joey's dog I've
been trying to tell you [ __ ]
all these dudes [ __ ]
opening up we got perennial og
we had hardcore G this is what they give
from the mental patients before they
[ __ ] take them off the meds and we've
got a little Skywalker
that's tremendous she understand me it's
nice and dry
oh I haven't even broken it up I'm
saving this look at that look at the
back end of that the mule is on the way
the filly already oh [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] excited but you know
what all the excitement go get the [ __ ]
might being sad of being I know we we're
gonna open up with this [ __ ]
perennial dope deep understand because
this is it
it's Wednesday you're got time to [ __ ]
around everybody's waking up it's hard
am gonna give a [ __ ] I do my best work
on a hump day you know why because it
don't matter about the Devery day you
shoot out the [ __ ] gate the same way
every day I'm at the gate the same
[ __ ] way
yeah shoot the gap how bad for fury who
gives a [ __ ] you know you wanna make an
omelet you gotta break some [ __ ] eggs
that's it
who gives a [ __ ] about your feelings or
who's he was supposed I don't give a
[ __ ] about them back
nice this wins [ __ ] tremendous you
don't meet dog when it comes to reefer I
go for the top of the food chain I don't
give a [ __ ] about another [ __ ] I'm
smoking dope for deep thirty years in
this family you wanna hang out with your
little [ __ ] [ __ ] friends and smoke
that [ __ ] here and make believe when
you smoke with me you leave there ya
isopentyl back here [ __ ] head you're
hearing things you're hearing people and
yelling and screaming at a night match
with you on a [ __ ] here in this
damage it's the painting your [ __ ]
soul coming
you people laughing [ __ ] you think the
craze is not crazy
that's the laugh let's and your [ __ ]
soul trapped and with the refrain lets
it loose ha ha ha
Iggy and there you got me understand I
may be old but there's always could
still run it's alright I had my smoothie
time I had my blood pressure medication
a couple CBD [ __ ] thing
I stuck with steroids in my nose I'm
ready to smell somebody's [ __ ] what's
up somebody's [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
she buys me food is what keeps us
together reefer is all from food from
the land of the free to the home of the
brave yet step they don't make me
split-second anthems hitters are [ __ ]
awful wake up the neighborhood how I'm
feeling today it's [ __ ] Wednesday got
slippin
grab your sax body and [ __ ] powder
your balls shine your shoes take your
[ __ ] money there you understand me
everybody's always asked wasn't my ship
gotta coming with my [ __ ] gonna coming
it's [ __ ] comin until they fill with
gold but at least you gotta think that
way
[Applause]
I see the mailman walking out on the
street I stand next to the mailbox at
attention because I know he's bringing
me a half a milk is he breaking me hath
no [ __ ] no but I'd make believes from it
brings my [ __ ] day for a minute yon
say it takes me out of hell I'm [ __ ]
it
now that would talk to them
you know [ __ ] Jesus it's my property
[ __ ] fool online
hey it's Wednesday today to get your
[ __ ] dick in hand don't come home
without a [ __ ] down the milk that's
it
you leave him with your dick and ham and
he can't come home without a gallon
Lopez I told myself unless okay maybe
it's [ __ ] me I got a lot to do today
I'm looking forward to it
he's [ __ ] Gentiles it's too hot when
you live in hell gives a [ __ ] about
it's the Mayans take three in the
morning here we are badger I always like
this [ __ ] lives like this does this
window
who does this us cuz you know why love
unity we don't give a [ __ ] we're
standing by ourselves the rest of these
[ __ ] think they know they don't
know big they went to Starbucks lying to
each other right now
and the Starbucks line to one another
well this week we were thinking I'm
traveling who gives a [ __ ] meanwhile
you're living off your [ __ ] cards why
the beep make him believe somebody left
your [ __ ] boat get the [ __ ] out of
here
all right if you haven't noticed
I'm stoned to the gills why because
that's the way that sometimes you smoke
a little too much and you know at least
I tell you the truth I'm not gonna sit
yeah that pineapple parade is killing -
get the [ __ ] out of him last thing that
killed me was a shadow lady for
everything else
background music [ __ ] you
understand boy your Midwood Laura that I
Binga heapify it up I want a party
I love you [ __ ] have a great
day
don't take [ __ ] from nobody keep the
eyes open he's [ __ ] you know they're
everywhere these [ __ ] and always
remember you're [ __ ] America nobody
can [ __ ] stop you they all gotta suck
your dick at the other day with a Paul
Revere don't stay black uncle Joey
lotion